so in what was completely predictable news
from day one, Donald Trump claims to have
fired
his third national security advisor or Radek
pro war maniac chicken hawk, John Bolton.
And when I say claims to a fireman, I say
that because Bolton is claiming that he wasn't
fired, but he actually resigned in Donald
Trump.
Only later announced it as a firing in order
to save face, which would not be a non-common
move for Donald Trump.
Here's the story.
First, as per Trump presented obviously on
Twitter where Donald Donald Trump tweeted
yesterday, I informed John Bolton last night
that his services are no longer needed at
the White House.
I disagreed strongly with many of his suggestions
as did others in the administration and therefore
I asked John for his resignation, which was
given to me this morning.
I thank John very much for his service.
I will be naming a new national security advisor
next week.
Now on the other hand, John Bolton's take
on it is different.
John Bolton tweeting quote, I offered to resign
last night and president Trump said, let's
talk about it tomorrow.
So this disagreement about whether it was
a firing or a resignation is not an uncommon
one in diplomatic circles and an administrations
that are riddled with controversy and farcical,
uh, a positions being held open for long periods
of time and a revolving door cast of characters.
But there are close to like a dozen different
and accurate reactions that we could have
to this because there are so many different
kind of layers to the John Bolton, Donald
Trump relationship.
First obviously from day one, just knowing
Trump's personality and knowing John Bolton's
personality, it was completely predictable
that the combination of Trump and Bolton was
never going to work longterm.
And in some senses it's a shock that it worked
as long as it did to the extent that it did
and it doesn't appear to have been working
very well.
Secondly, Bolton was a terrible choice on
policy from the get go.
So there are ways in which Bolton out isn't
bad per se, but as usual with Donald Trump,
an empty position can be bad because it allows
Donald Trump to do whatever the hell he wants
with no or very little push back.
Very often when Donald Trump gets rid of someone
who is bad, uh, they end up being replaced
with someone that is even worse.
So in that sense, it's kind of a delicate
and complicated situation.
Now, number three is the broader theme here,
which is the chaos in the Trump administration
at the highest levels.
Donald Trump will soon be if he actually does
select someone next week as you claims that
he's going to, Trump will be on his fourth
national security advisor in his first term.
And there's also a really good chance that
the position ends up unfilled for a long period
of time, which has been another trend and
theme of the Trump administration.
So if we were to zoom out, the theme or trend
is incompetent people either in way over their
heads or just terrible people on policy pushed
into positions where they don't get along
with Trump.
Ultimately fired or resign a constant revolving
door of incompetent, unqualified or otherwise
terrible people for jobs.
And or that being, uh, happening in conjunction
with positions just being empty for long periods
of time, which is also a terrible thing in
a number of different ways, which we've discussed
now.
Number four, maybe the most immediate question
in terms of, of impact in the short term,
which is what does John Bolton's departure
mean in terms of the possibility of a specific
military engagement or war somewhere on planet
earth?
Because instinct is not incorrect in that
Balt Bolton is a warmonger who very likely
could have, have been pushing Donald Trump
towards war, uh, in a lot of different places.
And now that Bolton is gone, is Donald Trump
less likely to get involved in certain conflicts?
Maybe, but it's not nearly that simple.
It could merely be that Donald Trump will
want to do different military engagements
than John Bolton would have wanted.
When you look at the actual areas of conflict
and disagreement between Donald Trump and
John Bolton, it's all potentially worse without
Bolton, which is scary to say, but maybe not.
I mean, I, I'm not speaking rhetorically here.
Uh, who to negotiate with was something that
Donald Trump and John Bolton didn't agree
with.
There was a split that developed between Bolton
on one side and Palm Peo and Trump on the
other side when it comes to who should we
be negotiating with and who should we not
be negotiating with?
Bolton was skeptical about Donald Trump's
approach to North Korea, which is logical
on the one hand because Donald Trump's approach
to North Korea has been a joke, uh, where
Trump has gotten absolutely nothing but thinks
that he's won something major.
Meanwhile, Kim Jong UN continues to pull the
wool over Trump's eyes.
But just because Bolton disagreed with Trump's
terrible take on North Korea doesn't mean
that Bolton's would have been better.
Bolton's might've been let's bomb a people.
Let's start getting even more aggressive with
North Korea.
Bolton said, don't pull troops from Syria,
which, I mean, this is crazy.
I would love to get our troops out of Syria.
But the way in which Trump did it completely
haphazardly, not as part of any kind of broader
plan was also terrible.
So like, where are we better off with Bolton
on Syria or are we better off without bolting
on Syria?
I don't know the answer.
Disagreements about whether to try to meet
with Iran.
Uh, so what's completely outrageous about
the situation in which we find ourselves is
that Bolton's ideas on most foreign policy
issues are horribly backwards, but he was
fighting against Trump whose ideas and implementation
of those ideas is often just as backwards
or even more in slightly different ways than
John Bolton represented it.
It's unclear who we are.
Worse off with Donald Trump or Bolton when
it comes to national security, which is a
stunning 2019 to be living in.
I want to be clear, I'm not defending Bolton.
I think the guy is one of the worst chicken
hawks who, uh, you know, he, I actually understand
why he avoided going to Vietnam.
I would have done the same thing if I was
potentially draftable at the time, but he
was talking about how, uh, it was a, you know,
something he wanted to do, even though he
believed that it was lost.
He was one of the big advocates for all sorts
of military engagements despite having himself
gotten out of them.
And again, I, I don't, I understand why one
would do that, but this is not the type of
guy you want making national security decisions.
Bolton was one of the primary people involved
in the neo-con plan to invade Iraq twice,
sold the idea to George W. Bush.
I mean truly, truly terrible, and yet he at
least understands a few more things than Donald
Trump and may have been slightly less bad
on some issues.
It's a really perplexing geopolitical sort
of status quo or circumstance these days.
Who wants to set the over under, by the way,
on how long this position stays open.
Donald Trump said next week he would be selecting
his fourth national security advisor in his
first term.
Do we believe that?
Do we believe that that person is going to
have a fighting chance of actually being confirmed
to the position?
I don't know.
I guess we'll know in about a week's time.
Let me know what you think.